dieses quarantäne chaos das ist überall
anders geregelt wird er ist nicht gut
das einmal klar zu machen für alle
gleich ich finde es wichtig dass wir
jetzt auf lokale lösungen setzen weil
die lokalen lösungen haben akzeptanz sie
sind in der regel ja sogar mit den
leuten vor ort entwickelt worden mit den
schulleitungen mit denjenigen mit den
schulträgern und insofern ist das
meistens die beste lösung ich glaube wir
sollten anerkennen dass in einer krise
eine einheitliche lösung niemals für die
richtig gute lösung sorgen kannst also
ich höre nicht dass eben flächendeckend
jetzt gesagt wird wir sind damit nicht
zufrieden aber 300.000 schüler und
schülerinnen sind schon wieder in
quarantäne 30.000 lehrer sind in
quarantäne
das ist doch eigentlich schon wieder
einschleichen der lock down an den
schulen wenn die schulen in diesem loch
darin die einzigen sind die noch im
grunde viele männer viele menschen sich
treffen dann ist es logisch dass an
dieser stelle die staaten die zahlen
steigern und das zweite ist dass wir
sehr klar eben gesagt haben wir wollen
sie offen halten und das bedeutet
natürlich dass man dann auch großzügig
in quarantäne schicken muss wenn
irgendwo etwas auftritt insofern würde
ich das eher positiv sehen weil das
sorgt dafür wenn 300.000 nicht in die
schule gehen
dass dann aber elf millionen in die
schule gehen können weil wir haben fast
11,5 millionen schüler und insofern ist
das immer noch eine sehr sehr kleine
zahl und ich denke wir werden jetzt auch
sehen dass die zahl wieder abnehmen wird
wissen sie selbst für sich eigentlich
bei der arbeit wenn so ein fall eintritt
wann muss ich in quarantäne wie ist das
genau geregelt auch mit der familie und
so weiter
wissen sie das ganz klar für sich und
wenn ich es nicht weiß was ich aber
wenig fragen kann hier in denjenigen der
dafür zuständig ist es gibt recht klare
zuständigkeiten in deutschland für alle
möglichen dinge und dann muss man sich
da erkundigen und meistens kriegt man ja
auch eine sehr freundliche auskunft und
weiß dann auch wie man sich richtig
verhält oder niemanden der abschied beim
gesundheitsamt nach das glaube ich jetzt
nicht